good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the major problems of the
world
so today's message is act despite fear
over to you Elon Musk you are unusually
fearless and willing to go in the face
of other people telling you something
that's crazy
and I know a lot of pretty crazy people
you still stand out where does that come
from or how do you think about making a
decision when everyone tells you this is
a crazy idea where do you get the
internal strength to do that I love us
all I'd say I actually think I see if
he'll fare quite strongly so it's not as
though I just have the absence of fear
I've I feel it quite strongly but there
are times when something is important
enough you believe in it enough that you
do it in spite of fear so speaking of
important things like people shouldn't
think III should if it was you think
well I feel fear about this and
therefore I shouldn't do it
it's normal to be to feel fair like
you'd have to definitely something
mentally wrong because you shouldn't
feel fair so you just feel it and let
the importance of it drive you to do it
anyway yeah you know actually something
that can be helpful as fatalism some
degree if you just think it's just
accept the probabilities then that
diminishes fear so we're starting SpaceX
I thought the odds of success were less
than 10% and I just accepted that
actually probably I would just lose lose
everything but that maybe would make
some progress if we could just move the
ball forward even if we died maybe some
other company could pick up the baton
and move and keep moving it forward so
that we still do some good yeah same
with Tesla I forget odds of a car
company succeeding or extremely loved
fear is normal it's part of what makes
you human you would not be human or
you'd have some crazy condition if we
never felt fear I think the people who
say don't be afraid aren't giving
you practical advice be afraid feel the
fear and then step into it and do it
anyway and the more you get used to
picking on those fearful projects that
you're scared of the stronger you'll get
the more resistance you'll get the
higher tolerance you'll get to do bigger
better bolder badder things I think the
trick though is spotting the fear here's
what I think happens to most people
there's some opportunity that comes
along there's some moment that comes
along with us with a client or meeting
somebody or an event hopefully comes
along that you're afraid of you're
afraid of doing it it's going to stretch
you beyond we've ever done before and
then what you do is you rationalize
saying no I don't have the money to go
to that event I'm too busy to go and do
that thing right now you find the reason
why you can't go and do it you
rationalize it but really deep down the
reason is you're just afraid and until
you spot the fear until you understand
that it's really just the fear then
you're never going to sell the problem
so step one is understanding when there
is fear step two is then stepping into
it and doing it anyway and a lot of this
stuff which is so subconscious you know
we as human beings are kind of trained
to when we're afraid something's going
to go wrong and to be safe and so it's
trying to catch that subconscious action
and proactively change it so as an
example for me when I was starting my
youtube channel my agent would tell me
you have to go out and do videos in
public I want you to go it on the street
I make your video in public my natural
reaction was ear but I didn't catch it
initially it was the gear won't be as
good in public you know I can't control
the light settings I'm going to be
bouncing around with a camera it's not
going to be a good experience for the
people watching why would I do that
I'm rationalizing a reason why I don't
have to do it we're really I'm just
afraid right you could solve all those
problems and he told me stop being
afraid and just go and do it he cut
through it and let me see my own fear
and so I did it and when I first went
out and filmed in public
I took out it was my phone or my camera
I don't remember and I'm walking on the
street and then the postman is there so
as soon as I see the postman I quiet
down I could put the camera away
just walking normally and then when the
postman leaves I'm back to filming and
that time I know it it's like I'm doing
it because I'm afraid and I got pissed
okay next time I gotta speak up next
time I gotta do better and so I went out
and forced him stuff to go and do it
again and I was walking past and there
were these construction workers and
instantly again the the panic sets in
like people are watching the
construction workers like I know they
don't really even care about me what I'm
saying what's happening on the street
but I forced myself through it it was
awkward it wasn't great I think I had to
redo it again anyway but I I took the
step I got better at it I recognized the
fear and I jumped into it
and now to the point where I'll make
videos walking down the hall I make
videos when I'm at Disneyland Disney
World you know I'll make videos in the
streets of anywhere and there's still a
moment even now after how many videos
I've done there's still a moment of
who's watching I think it's natural
normal it's not as strong as it used to
be and more importantly it doesn't limit
me from doing the things that I want to
do and so botting the fear and not
rationalizing it away and not just doing
what your subconscious always does that
keeps you down where you are is so
important being truthful but the reason
why you said no or you're not taking
this opportunity just because you're
afraid and the answer to say no should
never be because I'm afraid you want to
reject your system so whenever that's
the answer because I'm afraid to do it
now you have to do it because you are
afraid now you have to go and do it and
you build your muscle to get stronger to
take on new opportunities so you don't
play safe and play small for the rest of
your life
so the question a today is I'm curious
what's one thing that you are afraid of
or recently we're afraid of that you
want to tackle
people will be brave leave it down the
comments below really curious to find
out I also want to give a quick shout
out to Dave Lucas from misfit
entrepreneur Dave thank you so much
you're picking up a copy of my book your
one word I hope you enjoyed the read man
and I really appreciate the support so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events Press
[Music]
the only way to deal with fear that I
found in my life is a couple ways one of
those ways is to turn it on itself and
ask yourself what am I afraid of I'm
feeling to that I got to be more afraid
of what I'm going to miss out on missing
out on the mission missing on who I'm
supposed to be missing in other words if
you're not getting rid of fear than use
their use fear or it uses you it's that
simple so you got to say okay what's the
price if I just stayed doing this what's
the price what I need to really can get
scared and I learn all this I don't
follow through that's something to be
scared about
and then that fear will get you over
your fear it'll push you through turn
fear in itself second way you can do it
is use what you've probably heard me say
because I use it there was 17 in my
little rocking-chair test right I'm
gonna I'm gonna sit myself in my rocking
chair I'm I'm 85 years old looking back
on my life and I say I didn't do this or
I did if there was one concept that I
would suggest to people to take a daily
confrontation with is fear the the
problem with fear is that it lies right
so fear tells you hey you know if if you
say that to that girl she's going to
know she has you you know and she'll
never really be attracted to you if she
knows how much you attracted to her
don't say that know how we get her is
when she walked by ignore her I supposed
to do nothing like something on your
shoulder fear tells you dumb like that
okay you know so for me the the daily
confrontation with fear has become a
real practice for me since about three
three years ago I went I went skydiving
in Dubai right as skydiving skydiving is
a really interesting confront with fear
right so so I guess I got to stand up up
we're going to do it right
so so all your friends what happens you
go out how you oh sorry
job I think so what happens is you go
out the night before
and you you know you take a drink with
your friends and somebody says yeah we
should go skydiving tomorrow and you go
yeah we'll go skydiving or yeah yeah and
you'll get everybody goes yeah right and
you go home but you by yourself you like
in right you like well I mean they was
drunk too right so so maybe maybe they
not maybe maybe I mean we don't have to
go we like to do it so then that night
you're laying in your bed and you just
kick you and you're terrified you keep
imagining over and over again jumping
out of an airplane and you can't figure
out why you would do that right and
you're laying there you have the worst
night's sleep of your life but you still
have the hope that your friends were
drunk right so you wake up the next day
and you go you know down and you say
where you were going to meet and
everybody there you're like uh alright
cool cool cool cool cool cool right so
you get in the van and you don't know
that your friends had the same night
that you had condemned pretended like
they didn't it like yeah man my uncle is
a Navy SEAL and you know it's going to
be great I've been looking forward to
this you like oh my god oh my god
and your stomach is terrible you can't
eat and everything but you don't want to
be the only punk who doesn't jump out of
this airplane so you get there and then
you have this safety brief and you're
standing there and the guys would say
what the chute doesn't open what's going
to happen is you're doing your bottle
help with what could happen but the shoe
the shoe wouldn't open right so you do a
thing and what you do is your first jump
you're attached to a guy who is going
you and all he's going to walk you up so
you go and you get there and there's an
airplane and nobody's stopping
everybody's still going so you get onto
the airplane and you're sitting there
and and you know it's extra because
you're sitting on some dudes lap some
stranger you sit on a glass and it's all
you know you get trying to make small
talk yeah man
so you deal you'd be you be jumping with
people all the time huh
right you know what's so and then you
just want to make sure you got you got
kids right you got people you need to
see that's right you want to make sure
he's serious right so you get in there
so everything is normal so you fly and
you go up you go up you go up you go up
to 14,000 feet and you notice there's a
light it's red and it's yellow and green
right so right now the lights red so
then you start thinking at some point
the lights going to go green because you
don't know what's going to happen right
and you wait and it goes yellow and the
light goes green and somebody opens the
door and in that moment you realize
you've never been in a freaking airplane
with the door open right terror so sorry
I'm fit I'm work okay this is a terror
terror terror terror right so you go and
then you know if you're if you were
smart you sat in the back so you don't
go first right and then people start
going out of the airplane and you go and
the guy walks you up to the end of the
thing and you're standing and your toes
are on the edge and you're looking out
down to death and they say on three and
they say one two and he pushes you on to
because people grabbed on three right
and you go and you fall out of the
airplane and in one second you realize
that it's the most blissful experience
of your life you're flying right it
doesn't feel like falling right it's
like this you actually are kind of held
a little bit by the wind and then you
start and you start falling you falling
and you there's zero fear you realize at
the point of maximum danger
is the point of minimum fear it's bliss
it's bliss and you're flying
right and you're doing it and then 20
seconds 25 seconds 40 seconds and you
have enough time to just kind of like ah
[ __ ] that's it build it I sound like
that right you start doing all of that
and the lesson for me was why were you
scared in your bed the night before why
did you what do you need that fear for
just don't go why are you scared in your
bed 16 hours before you jump why are you
scared in the car why could you not
enjoy breakfast what would what did you
need if fear is fear of what you're
nowhere near the airplane everything up
to this stepping out there's actually no
reason to be scared it only just ruins
your day you don't have to jump and then
in that moment all of a sudden where you
should be terrified is the most blissful
experience of your life and God placed
the best things in life on the other
side of terror on the other side of your
maximum fear or all of the best things
in life